some creators start making some money
and then they just start buying dumb
stuff how can I strategically reinvest
into my business the first thing you
could do hire an editor I know high
level creators that edit every single
one of their own videos that could be
outsourced for a certain amount that
would allow you to produce even more
content and distribute that content
across all these platforms and we have
such a unique opportunity right now
where you can reach so many people as
these platforms are growing and new
products are growing that's like the
first thing of like hey you're making
this extra money maybe defer or like
delay gratification of you got this
extra money now instead of spending it
on something like the car or the trip or
whatever it is that you want put it into
the business with that new hire or with
that equipment that would upgrade the
look of your content